so that was always kind of hard to do
especially when you know inevitably a
lot of the scenes of every character
kind of was chopped down from the book
to the film so you kind of didn't really
have as much to kind of show in the film
so sometimes that was a little
disappointing because there were parts
of the character that just didn't get to
come through because there weren't the
scenes to do that so that made me feel
like a bit anxious or just frustrated I
guess yeah yeah because as great as you
were in in the movies it's like you know
some people say you were you know you
were underserved or like you know it's
like you know the book she should have
been more explored this character was
even better you know you could have they
could have made it you know and then of
course the the contrast or the the you
know I'm sure they thought we have so
many so much to do and so little time
and whatever but I'm sure it was a
battle the older you get and the more
you realize this is an integral part of
the movie the franchise